there are more food banks than
McDonald's in the
UK and when I heard that I just thought
I I don't I can't continue being part of
this system which is essentially
designed to keep concentrating wealth
and minimizing
tax all right Steph brbie I've been
trying to get on the channel for ages
thanks for coming and agreeing to do the
show thanks for having me um so as you
know on the channel we talk a lot about
the rich and about tax and your
background is you are a tax adviser for
the very wealthy so I was hoping you
could help educate our audience a little
bit about what life is like for the very
rich and their tax situation so um could
you tell us a little bit about your
background and and what you used to do
yeah um so I grew up in West London my
parents are G and migrants they came
here in the 1980s and I grew up uh on a
counsil state um with my three siblings
and my parents and um lived in a kind of
regular working-class community in kind
of Shephard's B and then moved to
Hammersmith when I was about 12 still in
social housing but then I kind of moved
onto a really really fancy Street in
Hammersmith which was kind of my first
experience of wealth and privilege um
and that's actually how I ended up
getting work experience through meeting
people locally okay um so really kind of
changed um the trajectory of my life
just moving off an estate onto um a
street in Hammersmith that's a bit
similar to me in a sense cuz I when I
was 10 I passed my 11 plus I went to
grammar school and um I don't think I
ever would have become a Trader if it
wasn't for the the kids that there who
they sort of knew in the family these
are the best jobs that's what ended up
there yeah so that is what sort of
pushed you to go into the area went into
well I I was always really passionate
about Justice and um I wanted to become
a human rights lawyer and actually
someone on my street owned a law firm
super casual and she kind of arranged
for me to have work experience and um
you know I went to study law at
University at ciff University and to be
honest when I was studying for my law
degree I wasn't really into I wasn't
sure I was going to end up qualifying as
as a solicor I thought I might end up as
a civil servant or something um and but
what ended up happening was that I
qualified as a a a solicor I went to
train in the city as a solicor got
training contract which is like really
competitive everybody tells you it's so
competitive um and yeah that was my kind
of
first experience kind of lived
experience of what it's like to have
proximity to wealth and to kind of um
yeah witness how much wealth people have
access to and not just property and
assets but like social capital and kind
of cultural
capital so we talk on this channel about
wealth a lot and um one thing
that I think it's important for people
to realize
is so we were talking about this before
and I speak about it in my video what is
wealth when I was a kid my sort of
perception of what a rich person is is
somebody who earns like 60 70 grand a
year like when I was a kid that was like
you have that you're super super rich um
and I want to talk about a little bit
about what what it means to be rich and
what are the different kinds of Rich
what rich is because um this is a
question we get all the time on the
channel right what what level what is
Rich what do you mean by Rich and you
know I talk quite a bit about my sort of
personal level of wealth in the media
and so you know my background come from
a similar sort of background to you I
was pretty poor growing up I got a job
in the city I made quite a lot of money
quickly um now I've quit that and I do
this sort of job all the time and I'm
able to live off of that money that I
made but I'm not able to live like a
super luxurious life
um but I don't really have experience
personally of what what I would call
Super Rich which is people who have
wealth in the sort of tens of millions
such that even without working they can
make incomes in the sort of hundreds of
thousands and live luxurious lives so
were you working with people at sort of
that level of of wealth
yeah it was actually a real mixture of
people some were very very wealthy in
the tens of millions and a lot more and
some were I guess what we would consider
maybe you know in London in particular
we don't tend to think of this amount of
money as a lot of money because a lot of
people's houses are worth a few million
but the top I think it's the top 1%
richest households in the UK have net
wealth of 3.6 million um which doesn't
sound like a lot to some of us but
obviously it is a lot of money so any
anywhere between that kind of um that
kind of upwards of 3.6 million you know
people in the
1% and I want to talk a little bit about
these people because you know most
people don't have much direct experience
with people at that sort of level of
wealth um and even me having worked in
finance you know I didn't work with many
really really rich people one thing I
always remember when I was quitting the
city is um the bank really really didn't
want me to quit and one of the manager
took me into a room and he sat me down
and he said to me that amount of money
you made you think that's a lot of money
but it's not a lot of money you're going
to run out of money you're going to need
more money and you know I'd made
millions of pounds right and you know
like I've my dad used to work for about
20 grand a year and I remember thinking
no that's a lot of money but I thought
it was an interesting mindset the way
that this guy who I'm sure was richer
than me because he' been working in the
industry for a lot longer than me he
thought it's not a lot of money and how
do you think these people who have might
have wealth of say5 million1 million how
do you think they
perceive themselves and their level of
wealth and their fam's level of wealth
it's really interesting actually because
I think there's this whole um you know
people can be a objectively very rich um
but they feel poor um there's this
mindset around I guess it's scarcity
right we've been socialized into a
culture that um says that we should
accumulate as much as possible because
you know resources are scarce and um
even very wealthy people will still
Benchmark themselves against someone
like Bill Gates and say well I'm not
Bill Gates but there still you know at
the end of the day in the UK If we know
that the top 1% households richest
households in the UK have 3.6 million at
the very minimum you know we know that
people have a lot of money um but yeah
there's this real culture around
scarcity and um the need to preserve the
need to pass down assets to Future
Generations um and it's interesting to
see one of that was one of the things
that I observed during my time in
practice was that people didn't feel
wealthy um you know even if they had
tens of millions of pounds yeah so it's
just quite interesting I think the
narratives around what what is wealth
and what what does it mean to be rich
you know yeah um I wanted to ask you a
little bit about um interaction with
these people personally because um
the work you're doing now you do a lot
of work talking to very wealthy people
about how they feel about their wealth
and how they manage their wealth and how
they can manage that to help society and
I've done some stuff with the
organization so I've met some of these
people and um I think it's for me what
was interesting
is you know often on my channel I say we
need to tax the rich and I say the rich
are damaging Society but when you
interact with these people I think it's
important one thing I think is people to
understand this these are not sort of
these are not like Bond villain type
people you know they're they they're
they're real people with with families
and emotions and with fears and you know
and
sometimes they're concerned about the
future so what's your interaction of of
these people because I think people
watching who might not have a chance to
interact with these people want to know
basically what they like yeah I mean
they're they're human beings like you
and me you know they have a lot you know
emot
uh they have a lot of challenges that
they face particularly people that I'm
working with who really care about
social justice um they feel a lot of
guilt a lot of anxiety around how much
money they have lots of them feel like
they have too much wealth they don't
know how to redistribute it they don't
know what responsible wealth stewardship
looks like um you know particularly if
they want to um help tackle things like
climate change and inequality they feel
really stuck you know and don't really
know what to do and it's also just it's
quite a burden for a lot of people even
for uh people that aren't necessarily
social justice oriented I noticed when I
was practicing as a lawyer um you know
people it was a great source of anxiety
you know when you've got so much wealth
yeah um all the decisions you have to
make all the you know all the the
different things that advisors put in
front of you decisions about tax
decisions about how you protect and
preserve and pass down assets yeah it's
a funny sort of conversation to have
because I know a lot of people will be
watching and they'll be thinking well it
sounds right to me I would like to do
but you know for me personally as
somebody who came from a very poor
background and made quite a lot of money
although I'm not super rich it it it was
actually quite a stressful experience
because you know no one in my family
ever had money when I made money I was
super young I was like 24 25 right like
I had nobody to turn to for like what do
I do with this money and and it's
weirdly in a bizarre way like kind of
kind of terrifying like I remember I
remember when I got my big bonus in 2011
when I was city stop Trader I got big
bonus the end of the year and my my
girlfriend at the time she came around
to my house that evening and I was like
sitting in my little office space in the
corner of the room like working out with
these spreadsheets and you know she was
like what what are you doing like you
seem stressed out and I was like look
I've got all this money I need to invest
it it's it's really important it's of
course I'm stressed out and she was like
if I had as much money as you the last
thing I'll be doing is sitting in the
corner of my front I'm stressing about
it of course she was right but if you
you know it's for me it was quite scary
like knowing how do I do what do I how
do I protect this you know what I mean
and I think yeah if you're from a
wealthy family youve probably I guess
been raised with this idea this isn't
important it's your legacy you need to
protect it I suppose yeah and and Ian
it's interesting the different
narratives that we have when we come
from poorer backgrounds where we're
afraid of losing the money a lot of the
time um and then you know people from
wealthier backgrounds will see the
opportunities that come with wealth
right and so um thinking about different
Investments like I I was always really
fascinated by um you know when I when I
started working and I realized that
people bought you know there were cash
buyers that existed and I've never
MH I just never ever thought that anyone
would have a few million pounds spare to
invest in property and buying cash but
then um another thing that I found
really interesting was is that you know
lots of people chose to even though they
had the cash they would get Finance they
would raise debt and you know you ra
idea like you should avoid that and I
think a lot of people are raised with
this idea you should avoid ITT as you
totally and that was always my you know
I'm to this day I'm still very risk
averse when it comes to debt but I think
if you if you've been raised to see that
actually debt you finance you know is a
tool you can use it as a that you can
leverage to create more wealth it's a
completely different mindset so how was
it what was it like for
you personally going into that space you
know
not realizing
beforehand that people you know that
people had this kind of money how did
you as a person and how did you
experience that yeah it was quite it was
quite daunting I was I was quite aware
of you know very aware of I don't know
what your experience was like but I was
very aware of where I was coming from in
society and entering you know even the
city being in the city being in a big
office it's quite an intimidating space
if you're not used to I don't know going
see your dad after work in the city or
you know whatever like I'd never really
been in those kinds of environments um
yeah so yeah it was very daunting I was
very aware of my position the law is um
you know quite hierarchical yeah um for
me I was never I was never intimidated
in the space but I had no idea how much
money those people were making seriously
like I thought like these guys were
making like 100 150 Grand a year like
which to me was like that's crazy money
like I was getting paid 40 Grand a year
and I was like this is like I thought I
was like a baller 40 Grand a year and I
was thinking these guys and then when I
realized that these guys are making like
millions of pounds a year it
was on the part of me is thinking wow
this is an opportunity and part of me
was just thinking like this is crazy I
can't part of me was actually shocked
and upset I think yeah because it made
me think of my dad and my mom and my
friends parents and how hard they used
to work for like you know literally
something like 2% of what these guys are
making yeah for me it was just I think
confusing yeah is confusing because
you're you're what's effectively
happening is you're entering a new world
which has completely different culture
and kind of social order I mean one of
the things that I remember quite early
on in my career I don't know if I was a
trainer or whether I was just quite
early on post
qualification was um when you work in a
law firm you tend to have like these
client codes um and then and then you
have like matter numbers yeah and I
noticed that there were some clients
that just had so many different matter
numbers which kind of um cross reference
to various property
purchases and I had this realization
that gosh it's the same people or the
same types of people that own so much
property all over the country and all
over London whether it's residential
property or commercial property and
that's when I think that was when the
seed was planted around becoming a bit
more politicized round what does this
what implications does this have for my
you know I really rep hard for London
because I'm you know you know I grew up
here I'm really proud to be a Londoner
and I started to think what is this
doing is this preventing people like me
getting on the property ladder I think
that's a really a good point and
important for people to realize and it's
a point I make in my what is wealth
video which is look at all this wealth
around you you know not just all the
properties but all the commercial wealth
as well it's all owned it's all owned
and if you come from an ordinary
background like we do you don't know
people who a shopping center you don't
know people who own 10 properties
outright no mortgage you just don't
think that kind of thing is possible but
there are people who own way more than
that there are people who own hundreds
of properties you know what I mean and
think about the income they make from
that you know think and then think about
like you say what does that mean for the
rest of us you know if they're if they
own 100 properties and they're making 20
million pounds a year you know and your
kids are competing with their kids you
know um so I want to talk a bit about
the financial situation of these kinds
of very wealthy people so um
um my understanding is a lot of these
very wealthy people essentially don't
need to work regular jobs because they
can make a lot of income from the wealth
that they have would you say that's
correct yeah so there are I suppose
people that make money through rent like
through you know either commercial or
residential property um there are people
that you know will take a huge dividend
you know you know every year and so
they're not deriving their they're not
living off income that they're working
for it's maybe investment it's you know
investment income either from an
Investment
Portfolio um or uh you know property or
kind of business income essentially one
point I always like to make on this is
like if there's somebody who's making
income and they're not working for it
somebody else is working for it and in
that that money doesn't just spring out
of the ground you know what I mean that
comes from when you pay a rent when you
pay a mortgage or when you when you have
commercial transactions a chunk of that
goes to the own of the businesses the
owners of the assets yeah so I'm always
trying to get people to realize there is
this cash flow which is constantly going
from Ordinary People to the owners of
assets and you know I'm not super rich
but I'm a relatively wealthy person as
well so that that includes me you know
people who don't own assets are
continually giving money to people who
do ear assets yeah and I guess you got
to think about the broad implications of
that in society so someone who makes a
living from developing properties you
know doing them up and then selling them
at a profit what is that doing to the
market what's that doing how's that
affecting ordinary people and their
ability to buy homes yeah that's point
I'm always always I think I'm always
trying to make that connection basically
between and I think what's Happening Now
is really highlighting that like if the
rich get richer does that affect you
because in covid we saw this massive
increase of the wealth from the rich and
it was easy so number one it's easy to
not notice that like if the rich make a
ton of money you know you don't see that
that happens to them but does it affect
you well if they have a the money well
they're going to push up house prices
they're going to buy assets they're
going to buy Commodities you know it's
going to make your life more expensive
so I'm always trying to make that
connection because for me what I do you
know we spoke about these guys are not
they're not Bond villains they're
Ordinary People I've got no hatred for
the rich I myself am a rich person but
what I am is an economist you know and I
think if these guys are generating huge
amounts of income and buying more and
more of their assets and taking more and
more of the share of the wealth then
it's going to make allary people poorer
yeah I mean I think a point I always
like to make is that
wealth is not created in a vacuum and
this is you know it's not about
demonizing wealthy people I actually had
really good relationships with a lot of
my clients back you know when I was a
solicor um and they were really nice
people but wealth is not created in a
vacuum there's there's a whole you know
it's in the context of a broader
economic system there are political
choices that are made in order to enable
you and facilitate um certain people
certain groups of people certain
demographics um to benefit and to to
grow their wealth or to create wealth
yeah this this is the point I'm always
trying to make is look I've got nothing
against rich people but what I don't
like is ordinary families being driven
into poverty and these things or in my
opinion connected okay but what I want
to talk about now is tax yeah um so we
all hear it in in the press that very
rich people don't pay much taxes you are
probably the expert to talk about that
is that true well I think what I
realized I mean I mean one of the things
just by way of background I was on an
amazing career directory I loved I loved
my job I used to skip into work I
thought it was brilliant I was you know
had the intellectual and academic
stimulation I had great relationships
with my clients my team were absolutely
amazing um and I loved it um but it was
over a number of years that I started
becoming quite politicized around wealth
and typically around a budget or an
Autumn statement or you know when you
would hear about the threat of a labor
government um I started to think what
you know surely if you're generally if
you're forc to pay more tax you're
generally on The Winning Side of Life so
what why are there all these really
negative narratives around tax that are
kind of coming out of the industry that
I'm working in so you know a lot of my
yeah essentially I am
the Catalyst for leaving my job was
realizing that my work was being really
skilled and doing well at my work was
having an impact a detrimental impact on
our economy and specifically depriving
our government and probably some
governments around the world um you know
when dealing with International clients
depriving those governments of their
ability to raise taxes the the correct
amount of Revenue to invest in public
services um and this this all came to a
head when a friend of mine told me on
New Year's Eve um in 2019 that there are
more food banks than McDonald's in the
UK and when I heard that I just thought
I I don't I can't continue being part of
this system which is essentially
designed to keep concentrating wealth
and minimizing tax so a lot of my job
was to um you know I did a lot of
succession planning and Advising on kind
of asset protection and asset
preservation
um helping people to pass down assets
that you know their wealth to their
families their children
grandchildren um and that would
invariably involve a level of tax advice
normally around what we call Capital
taxes so inheritance tax capital gains
tax um on sort of gifts and inheritance
and that kind of thing and you know I
realized that I was by giving this
advice I was directly contributing to
this problem that we have now where the
government doesn't have enough Revenue
to invest in public services I I think
that's it's super relevant to what's
happening now and this is something
which I've spoken about a lot in the
last sort of few months of videos which
is we've got this narrative which was
happening now everybody knows there's an
economic crisis like everybody can see
that right it's affecting people
directly and everybody wants the
government to help and the government is
saying oh there's only so much we can do
right and
nobody ever talks about the fact that in
the last two and a half years we've seen
the biggest and fastest ever increase in
millionaire and billionaire what that
the average billionaire increased their
wealth by 22% in the first one year of
Co that 450 billion pound went from the
government to the rich right like the
government gave 450 billion P to the
rich and now they're saying well I'm
sorry there's no money and I think this
sort of perfectly draws
that that connection that look if if the
rich don't pay taxes affect the rest of
us you know and I think it's important
to realize you
know public services will still have to
be provided and if the rich don't pay
taxes somebody else has to and you know
I I was in a situation and you might
have been in this situation yourself
where you are working for people
bringing their tax level down and
they're able to do that pay low level of
taxes because they're getting income
from wealth whereas you who are getting
your income from working and probably
getting lower income than them I don't
know about you but I paid 50% income tax
when I was working so were you in a
situation
where you were paying high rates of tax
and the people you were working for who
are much richer than you um that's an
interesting question I mean
I I suspect in some cases when you look
at the proportion of my income that was
taxed um yeah perhaps it was overall um
that that I was paying proportionately
higher taxes than
than some of the people I worked with
for sure um particularly people that are
relying on dividend income you know
rental income um when you TOS up how
much tax you're paying as an ordinary
person you know V you're bearing council
tax and income tax National Insurance
and it's it's a lot and when it comes to
passing like large amounts of wealth
down from generation to
generation would you say very rich
families and very rich people are
generally able to do that at very low
levels of
tax um I think it depends on I think it
depends on how things are structured in
some cases yeah uh particularly if
there's an offshore element so if if
there's you know some wealth is held in
a a different country um there's
definitely ways where there's almost no
tax at all um but for mainly people that
are based in the UK um there are ways
that they can pass on significant assets
without paying any tax at all um there's
a the kind of seven-year rule where you
know you you can make a gift however
large or small and if you survive seven
years from the date of making that gift
then you know people escape inheritance
tax which ordinarily would be paid when
you die um yeah what I find interesting
about this is you so if if you put
yourself in the shoes of a wealthy
family and and you know there are a lot
of families have some level of wealth
it's often not much and they're thinking
about preserving that wealth um you can
kind of understand okay well we've got
this wealth we want to preserve it we
want to pass it down but if you think
about the consequence of that you know
if you imagine a wealthy family that has
say assets of 20 million which is not
crazy crazy Rich they're much richer
families and they want to manage their
wealth such that they pass it all down
without being able to pay any tax you
know if you got 20 million pound you're
going to generate income every year
about 600,000 right
so if these families are able to
preserve their wealth it also means they
will never ever sell any assets right
they will only ever buy assets they will
only ever accumulate assets which also
means
that the other young people from other
families that don't have assets won't
have access to those assets so that the
flip side of sort of wealthy people
preserving their wealth is you basically
guarantee that young people from poor
families will never be able to buy
property I think this is sort of this
and it's that connection that I want
people to understand which is look if
you if you guarantee that all of the
assets belonging to the rich will stay
belonging to the those people's kids you
also guarantee that young people from
poor families will never get assets and
I think this is a really important part
of the housing crisis to understand
which is look if you give all of the
houses to the rich people and you put
rich people in a situation where they
will never ever sell any houses then of
course no one else will ever be able to
buy a house you know I think this is the
it's that connection people don't
understand which is
look being rich might be great for rich
people but if you allow them to get
richer and richer and richer is
inevitable that ordinary families will
get get poorer you see the connection
I'm trying to make well yeah they get
poorer but also in a way kind of
disenfranchised from the the economy the
economy that they prop up by you know
yeah spending in the in the real economy
you know
um it's uh yeah it's I I think you know
one rule that I developed was follow the
money you know there's these ongoing
wealth transfers in favor of someone
that happening all the time yeah when we
spend every time we spend money or pay
rent one thing that upsets me is like
how difficult it's become for you know I
had a very good job and I was very well
paid and you know I've been to Elite
University so I know other people that
have good jobs and well paid and what I
see is my friends even have really good
jobs earning much higher than average
they can't afford property and they
don't really understand how and why
that's happening you know if you know
I've got a friend who earns like 70
grand he's much higher than the average
he's living with his mom he's saving up
every pent you can't afford to buy a
house and the flip side you see these
people from very rich families might
even work get getting houses sort of
given to them and paying no tax on it
and I just think the um what upsets me
most is that Ordinary People are not
really being told the true story about
what's happening they're getting these
stories in newspapers about what it's
because you're going to Starbucks too
much yeah you spending all your money on
smashed avocado and poach X you know
like it's but it's you know that's
something that I really noticed and
that's the difference between wealth and
income right if you have a family that
will give you a 250,000 deposit depos
it so you you know you don't have to
take out a massive mortgage your your
level of income is relatively
insignificant but you you're you're
someone you know compared with someone
who has a high income but doesn't have
assets behind them you know that's
that's the difference between wealth and
income right you can't and that's the
point I really want to make which is
look this is not this is not about
hating rich people this is not this is
not a Witch Hunt this is about look
these people are ing the lives of
Ordinary People